what's up guys today we're gonna be
taking an in-depth look at the courser
cx-5 50m let's jump right in so once you
get off the plastic wrap around the box
there's just a little tiny little tab on
the right side maybe pull that off the
whole right side and the top come off
inside this little warranty guide in the
main you understand
tower kill that goes into the power
supply and here's the actual power
supply it's semi modular so has a 24
from cable and 8 pin CPU cable attached
let's take a look at what comes inside
this back so first there's some
molecules and there's some right angle
of SATA cables and there's some more
writing without a cable here here this
wall is the end it's real
in the middle of the street and here is
the 8-pin for the GPU that's all the key
wasn't coming in the back
there's some bubble wrap around the
power supply itself and the cable right
here is being held by little high
straight off
I'm sure there's there's some tape on
the bottom that's like those little
bubble wrap in power supply come
straight out
well guys that's it for the courser cx-5
50m detailed look and unboxing if you
guys liked it make sure to give it a
like and it's good slump and make sure
to subscribe if you guys want to see
more videos just like this I hope you
guys liked that video and be sure to
check out some of my other videos if you
guys liked it and until next time bye